ん
[音楽]
水で今回てみをこの大の大人2人だよね
セミを捕まえようと思いますあの頃の俺たちは弱かった
[音楽]
カメラバスで頷いても誰も見てないな米がお空になった
胸前な肉塊を持った今打ち取りをするとセミだねせ見るで行こう
セミを捕まえるとどれぐらい取れるのかっていうカード
なんとの今日は楽しいとかじゃないからのんびり見てくれればいいよいう
[音楽]
はいありがとうございます
これ
消防艇した
[拍手]
ブービーゲットしましたあーーヌー
はいここれはっ
折れちゃって飲んでろ
疲れてたんだようそやーん
anode ん
風の当たらないところに移動させました夏の終わりだからな
弱ってるもん
あいつもなくはない風がんだやる気ですよね
うわぁウェイク青っぽいん
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
ダメだってやってやる取材んです
普通
car
いいいいいいいん
は
[音楽]
ペットえっ
指図書等サーんんんん
tee
ところで書だけで3匹マーケットでこの捕まえてくださいね
水属性名 ren
あれちゃダメっちゃ普通に使う
はいああああそうそう
うつや dj ハーフ臼やんエガチャをざっと叩きそうじゃの
セッター
ren
me
からの今日つく前から
入れようと思ってそ
[音楽]
あったかなぁ
図面でもいるからな
はい
マッハ
摂津
まず
ますスラブすげえええは突っ込まれた終われ終われたと思いますはれたに打ってないよ
ねまだ
凄いきれい
全て込めたん
[音楽]
e 8 a ノッサですやばいでしょ
こいつくっつくボスってやってねえよでをも悩んでは作ってますでしょ
いやー覚えはめぐる受け付けませ get しました
酒
描き下ろしメっ
逃げないてる上焼けちゃってない中山
相手がいただけで結構捕まえましたこれどうすか20歳的にはございません弱ってる
選手もいるからね
勝手の悪いを走ったあとなんかもう夏終わりだなんて感じでした
ちょっとセミ取りしかすることがなかったので不安にがしましょう
[音楽]
まあねっ一局にそうなっちゃいますよね